if you think I look like a mess
you should see my house
I've had a busy morning
I started the day with a yoga class
and I came home
scooped up the kids and we went and ran
some errands for a few hours
on our travels we picked up some groceries
as you do
and unfortunately
my fridge is at that point where you can't
actually put new groceries in it
without sorting it out
normally I like to stay across the day to day
jobs a bit better than this
but when we're going hammer and tongs on a project
I find it extremely difficult to juggle everything
and I'm aware that realistically
if I was working side by side with Mark in the pool right now
we would be making faster progress
but I also need what I call my mummy days
I really need that one on one time with the kids
and I also need time to kinda organise the house
and get ready for the week ahead
so I'm chopping up some fruit for the fridge
because if I do this
it'll get eaten
and if I don't
it won't
I've also got two out of three kids sitting at the bench with me
and chopping up fruit in front of kids as such
a sneaky way to make them eat it
I think a big part of motherhood is
conquering the out of subtle manipulation
because I've just popped a little bowl in front
of them and the fruits there and wouldn't you know it
they're just helping themselves
side note
but I found chopping that watermelon
extremely fkn satisfying anyway
another good thing about making up these
fruit containers is at the end
I'll just chop up some of the fruit a little bit smaller
and then throw together a fruit salad
these don't last five minutes in my house
they're so yummy and we all love them
it's time to put everything back in the fridge
and I'm just gonna give you a warning now
my fridge is not a content fridge okay
my items stay in the packaging that I purchased them in and yeah
I kinda wish that I decanted them into beautiful aesthetic jars
but also I'm renovating I have 3 kids and I am at capacity okay
but it's a normal functional family fridge and we love her
fingerprints and all
alright we're on the home stretch now
I put away the rest of the groceries into the cupboard
unloaded the bottom dish drawer and then
got started on the dishes in the sink
then it was time to give everything a really good wipe down
can't forget the tap
and I love the tap
but the only downside of a tap with a motion sensor
is that it's easier to turn on
than my husband
I gave the sink a really good scrub down
and this I think is one of my favourite jobs
I don't know how long you've been following me for
but if you remember my old house
you will know the lore about the white sink
and saying goodbye to that sink was
probably the saddest part about moving
it took us a full year but I finally put a white sink into this place
and you might have noticed that
I haven't actually updated you on the kitchen renovation
in a hot minute
I was waiting for a few finishing touches to arrive and they finally did
so I'll be posting that series in the next few days
hopefully I say that but honestly
don't be surprised if is it’s delayed
because I just feel like I'm tryna do too many
things at once at the moment
and lowkey failing at all of them anyway
I use the sleepy moppy thingy on the floor before vacuuming the rug
and lighting a fk off candle
and if you don't know what that is
you just light a candle in an area that you've cleaned
and it will tell everyone in your house to fk off
mine smells like gingerbread
There’s no better feeling for me than a clean space
but then I remembered that now I have to make dinner
and it was basically pointless